[Música]
[Aplausos]
sabían que los 200.000 niños que nacerán
hoy en el mundo en el 2040 tendrán 21
años y la gran mayoría con una educación
en el hogar de 1970 80 y 90
ser padres es una tarea titánica no
tenemos un guión ni una orientación
profesional para hacerlo y como sociedad
históricamente lo hemos dejado al ensayo
y error nuestras abuelas castigaban a
sus hijos con correa nuestras madres
sacaron con menos frecuencia la correa
pero nos tenían amenazados con la
chancla voladora
luego los padres pasaron de la chancla
la guardaron y decidieron pasar a la era
del trueque si haces esto te doy lo otro
para llegar hoy día lo que yo llamo la
era del asistencialismo paternal
una era donde los padres le dan todo a
sus hijos
creando niños y niñas que sólo dependen
de alguien que sólo saben recibir
instrucciones y que les cuesta tomar
iniciativa hasta de sus propias vidas
saben que es hora de parar
en un mundo donde la principal
competencia será la capacidad de
resolver problemas con creatividad e
innovación
es nuestro deber como padres aprender a
enseñar en libertad y basados en valores
dejar a nuestros hijos de 35 10 y 15
años
de pensar y actuar y tomar
responsabilidad sobre sus propias vidas
y el mundo que le rodea
como madre de maipú y diana desprenderme
de ellas es motivarlos a ser
autosuficientes y enseñarlas a encontrar
solución a sus propios problemas
vivimos menospreciando a las nuevas
generaciones millennial y centenial
creyendo que el pasado fue mejor que el
presente pero saben que hoy padres los
quiero invitar a que dejemos libres a
estos chicos brillantes e inquietos
y pongamos el futuro del mundo en sus
manos porque si de algo estoy segura
aquello es el mejor legado que le
podemos dejar
[Aplausos]
[Música]